Morning, John. It's Monday. I haven't said that in years. This is weird.
For those who haven't been following us for more than a year, you might not know
that it´s about to get weirder here in this channel...
because the Project for Awesome happens in December 17th.
It's gonna start tomorrow at noon Eastern time, and you might not know what that means.
That's what this is about.
participates in the Project for Awesome.
The idea is to just spend one day of our internet experience, instead of on Super Wholock and cat gifs
spend it on making the world a better place.
We do that in a few different ways.
and then upload them on noon Eastern Time or thereabouts on December 17.
Two: People submit those videos to projectforawesome.com,
Three: There's an Indiegogo campaign. This is how we raise the actual money.
There's a Men of YouTube charity calendar. There's a Women of YouTube charity calendar.
We did both this year.
So let's see who wins...
A bunch of nerdfighters created their own artwork which they sent to us for free, even paying for postage,
You can get a haiku with your name in it made by George Watsky,
Also, in addition to that, you'll get his new CD, signed.
So I'm gonna make all of my shirts--
I'm gonna have-- these also are available. So you can get a shirt.
They're just my shirts. I now have six shirts. You'd also get this one.
They're all men's mediums, if you're wondering. The Indiegogo campaign is there to raise money.
Thank you, anonymous donor.
There is a livestream that starts also at noon Eastern time on December 17th.
Also, in addition to that, you'll get his new CD, signed.
And commenting on videos.
But mostly degenerating into madness. You don't want to miss it.
We'll watch a bunch of videos together, you'll comment on them, and if you like them you'll go and vote for them at projectforawesome.com.
And finally, Number Five:
After everyone has had a chance to vote the charities featured in the top voted videos will get a cut of the money
They're just my shirts. I now have six shirts. You'd also get this one.
They're all men's mediums, if you're wondering. The Indiegogo campaign is there to raise money.
Last year we raised four hundred thousand dollars.
This year, we have matching donations up to $125,000 from an anonymous donor.
Thank you, anonymous donor.
Four: We're still in a list, if you forgot.
There is a livestream that starts also at noon Eastern time on December 17th.
The livestream is basically everybody hanging out and slowly degenerating into madness.
And commenting on videos.
But mostly degenerating into madness. You don't want to miss it.
We'll watch a bunch of videos together, you'll comment on them, and if you like them you'll go and vote for them at projectforawesome.com.
And finally, Number Five:
After everyone has had a chance to vote, the charities featured in the top-voted videos
will get a cut of the money donated to the indiegogo campaign.
Everything that we don't spend on processing costs, or shipping, or printing, stuff like that,
goes to the fund to be split between these charities.
There's so many other perks that I haven't even talked about.
There's a chance to win a book signed by JK Rowling.
Oh right: the first two chapters of John Green's new thing that he's working on,
which I don't know if it's gonna become his new novel, but maybe.
I have a Christmas album, did Ieven mention that? I did a Christmas album for the Project for Awesome.
It's only-- it's digital only and it's six songs, maybe seven.
I... haven't quite decided. A lot of it's recorded but not all of it.
Anyway, there is much to do! The next few days are gonna be crazy.
The live stream is hosted here on the vlogbrothers channel,
so you can join us for that, please do.
Get your commenting fingers ready, and John I'll see you tomorrow.